Okay, kids,
now, remember,
Chief Woody will be watching
and keeping tabs.
Everything you do well
earns your tribe
valuable points
for the tribal shield.
Malloy here
will be keeping score.
On it.
Points!
Now it's time for a tour
of our wilderness wonderland.
Here is where the two best
cooks in the county
will delight your taste buds--
our mess hall.
- Oh, mess hall.
- Yeah, that makes more sense.
Above you is our
state-of-the-art ropes course.
[eagle screeching]
[zapping]
This doesn't look anything
like the brochure.
Where are the arcades
and the 100-foot water slides?
We have water slides!
Don't look
at that.
Why can't
we play outside?
Yeah, Steve,
it's a beautiful day.
It's way too dangerous
out there.
Steve, the best
counselor ever,
is going to keep
his kids safe.
Besides, we can do fun camp
activities right here.
See?
Aah! No.
You could choke on that.
Mmm, mmm.
[spits]
Steve,
this is ridiculous.
These kids can't spend
their whole week of camp
locked up in a cabin.
Connie, my kids
aren't stepping foot
out of this cabin,
and that's final.
(kids)
Aww!
All right, campers.
Time for an exciting hike
past the Brickleberry whirlpool!
I haven't had a group of kids
watch me poop
since I paid money to have
a group of kids watch me poop.
[laughing]